[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
aaron donald we
talked to him yesterday around three
o'clock eastern time we stayed to be
able to do the interview and we were the
first one to interview him
and uh we sent out some of the clips
that you'll hear
or you might have already heard
yesterday and that had to do with
uh the gulf stafford trade and uh
so we'll play the entire interview for
you and i start out by asking aaron
donald if
he wants to get the uh goffin-stafford
question
out of the way or if he wants to wait
till the end of the interview
we can wait till the end
are you already tired of talking about
it um i haven't talked to
this the first time i'm even gonna speak
out about anything so i i
really speak about it just with the
family and little conversations i had to
to the side but that's about it
okay why don't we knock it out first and
then you can say to people hey i've
already talked about it to dan patrick
i don't need to talk to anybody else
about it okay
uh your reaction when you heard that uh
jared was going to detroit and matthew
stafford was
coming to l.a i'm pretty sure everybody
was shocked with it but um
you know steph was a great quarterback
i'm i'm excited about having with the
team a veteran guy that
um know the game i've been playing the
game at a high level for a long time you
know
it was a business decision that the rams
organization chose to make
um you know i will always love golf you
know that's that's my brother forever
but
you know um i guess things didn't work
out how they wanted to so um
they made a change so have you uh sacked
stanford
yeah six thousand
[Laughter]
somehow you had that stat ready there
erin yeah i already told him if i said
that
i played two times and that's actually
three each time i played
i stacked him three times each game so
you know but here's the problem aaron
you want him to stay in detroit so you
can sack him more now he's going to be
your teammate
yeah no it's fine he's gonna make so he
gonna help us win some games so i'm
pumped up about that give me the most
unfair criticism of jared goff
uh i think there's a lot of things that
were said you know
but you know once you're starting
quarterback you know if things ain't
going i suppose it goes always gonna be
you know you can be talked about a lot
you know um i would never say nothing
bad about golf like i said that's that's
my brother you know always going to keep
in contact with him i'm always going to
talk i wish nothing but the best form in
detroit
um so you know we ain't going to worry
about you know the negativity that's
talking about you know he got a bright
future ahead of him
a fresh start and hopefully do you do
great things there so
how much do you play or the style of
play
deals with the chip that might be still
on your shoulder you know tom brady
still talks about being drafted in the
sixth round
uh drew brees you know that he was too
short to make the nfl like
guys carry that but i don't can you
carry it into a game do you have a chip
on your shoulder when you play
um i bet i've been asked that question a
lot
you know in my you know career playing
football just because you know you i had
a lot of negative talk about just my
size and things and
um teams not knowing if i was going to
hold up to be able to play at a high
level at this at this
in this league um so to me i i never
if anything it kind of motivated me
because i felt like i didn't do enough
to put it on film to show that
show the world that i can play this game
at a high level don't matter the size i
am
um so you know did it get me mad
no did it motivate me you could say yes
about that you know it just it just made
me work harder because i felt like
um you know maybe i didn't show them
enough yet maybe
you know i need i need to do that much
more to show to show the world what i'm
about what i can do and you know
that's what i do you know that's why i
work the way the way i work that's why
you know i put the body at work and how
i do every single off-season
um prepared myself to you know be
successful and help my team to win games
so
i'm going to continue to do that as long
as i play this game so do you know the
name of the offensive lineman that you
face every every game
oh not every game i know the numbers i'm
not i'm not i don't really care for
their names
there's a number i'm going to get but
that's it are you friendly with any
offensive lineman
not at all no none that's the guys that
that's that's the guy that's trying to
stop me from doing my job so i
i can't be friends with no guys they're
trying to prevent me from you know doing
what i got to do to provide for my
family so
on the field it's really no friendships
it's just
you know they they the enemy well what
about post game hug
when you could do hugs oh you know hug
probably high five or something but
honestly i really i know a couple of
offensive linemen
personally but i really don't have too
many relationship offense alignment so
what about quarterbacks you okay with
quarterbacks um
no you know anybody i gotta go against
or
you know that's trying to you know
prevent me from doing what i need to do
you know so i ain't too friendly with
him but during the game
you know it ended me but you know after
the game might
you know shake your hand and say what's
up that's about it anybody talk trash to
you
yeah there's some players talk trash
this year try to say some things here
and there but
you know it's a part of the game well
give me an idea you don't have to give
me a name but give me an idea what it
would
what did they say to aaron don what is
what could you say to aaron donald
it's a lot of it's a lot of trash
talking to football a lot of things that
can't be
spoke out loud you know but you know um
can't say exactly what it was but this
thing said and things would be sad back
and then you know actions
will be handled from there on the
football field so
we handled the right way when's the last
time you were in a fight off the field
i had been in the fight since i was a
kid man i'm too old to get a fight now
you fight now you go to jail so um
what was your what was your career
record as a kid
in fights
if they was too old and too big for me i
got my big brother to handle it
i never lost no fight only well i lost a
fight to my big brother but that don't
count
so why did the packers loss
affect you so much um
honestly um it was just i felt down just
because i wasn't able
to play how i needed to play you know i
had i had an injury that kind of
you know prevented me from being who i
am i wasn't able to do much
you know playing through pain and things
like that no excuses but
um you know it was just tough i felt
like i let my team down
um when they needed me the most i
couldn't be there for them you know so
it was just
that that's what that was that's what
hurt me the most you know because i felt
like
you know um you work your butt off to
play at this position and
do a lot to you know to have opportunity
to you know
playing big games like that and and i
get to that point and i and i got to try
to fight through an injury
and you know and and not be able to help
my guys how they needed me that day
you know i was just down about that so
well it's tough enough to be chasing
aaron rodgers when you're healthy
yeah this is fine man that's why
um he had a great year a lot of respect
for him but
you know it is what it is what's your
i'm bumming you out here i got a
i have to cheer you up right
now okay all right i know but yeah we're
ready you know
new sports drink out so we pumped up
about that
if i drink it will i play like you
it gives you wings how about that but no
um
no it's a great you know um it's
something that i became a
you know a partner with um i drink that
out this this
new sports drink is what we just dropped
you know it's amazing it
awfully it tastes good i feel like
that's what it starts with but not just
tasting good what you consuming good for
your body and what you
what you take it in good you know you
got the super fruit blend
you know that help with recovery um you
know
fight inflammation things that you need
to make sure that your body is fine as
far as
i'm recovering quicker you know as going
into my eighth year
um a lot of things that i learned about
you know recovering things like that of
what you consume what you put into your
body and and
um a lot of that go into what you're
drinking when you're working out when
you're training when you're practicing
and
and ready is that thing for me you know
so not just being able to you know be a
part of but
be part owner of it um it's huge so i've
been i've been loving the opportunity
and
um we just dropped this great sports
drink and we pumped up about it
greek freak's involved in this too right
yes yes sir yes sir how do you think
he'd do in the nfl
i think he did good he's a big guy
athletic guy i think he has some success
i don't know it like i could see lebron
is a tight end
okay do you think lebron could do okay
um he got the size and athletic ability
you know i think if if he practice it
just like he practice football i mean
basketball
yeah i think he can translate that to
the nfl now how would you do in
basketball
if i practice it good enough i think
i'll be good if i took it as serious as
i took football
um you know i think you could i don't
know there aren't too many
six foot three hundred pound point
guards here erin like
i obvious obviously my body will have to
change and things like that yeah a whole
lot
that's obvious but um you know anything
you work hard enough for you
you can you know accomplish some crazy
things if you put the body working so
well wait a minute who plays basketball
the way you did in high school
um i don't know and
don't say allen iverson or somebody like
that
well i'm a big body guy i'm more
dominant so i would say like a guy like
shaq
you know a girl [ __ ] like invite the
bully people a lot
and do a lot of things like that so but
you know guys in the nfl
say shaq would get destroyed in the nfl
because it's all about getting low it's
about getting leverage he's too tall
do you think shaq again if you think
about
you know if if he the way he took
basketball if he was took football the
same way
you know that was switching it'll
translate differently
i don't know he's too big no leverage
there
that that's why you're so great you got
leverage man every play you got
leverage hey uh good luck
i gotta get back to uh benching and uh
good luck with ready
and uh congratulations on the success so
far
i appreciate you thank you that's aaron
donald of my la rams